más de 60.000 personas han movilizado a
las inmediaciones de la kennece del
parlamento israelí para protestar contra
la propuesta de reforma judicial del
gobierno de Benjamín Neta ñahu hasta
aquí han llegado jóvenes adultos de
todas las edades y desde distintos
puntos de Israel bajo una Consigna
democracia y porque consideran que esta
reforma pone en peligro la independencia
del poder judicial
[Música]
está siendo investigado va a cambiar
todo el sistema judicial solo para
salvarse a sí mismo Pero esto es a Costa
de todos los demás ciudadanos
el gobierno israelí Está tratando de
hundir la rama judicial y así no
funciona una democracia
esta manifestación también fue
acompañada de un llamado a huelga que
fue acatado en algunas empresas del
sector privado sobre todo de tecnología
o también del área legal e incluso
algunos médicos que se sumaron a esta
movilización lo cual también continúa
con las movilizaciones que se han
repetido cada sábado desde inicios de
año y que hoy han llevado estas
movilizaciones masivas hasta Jerusalén
lo que sea que la Corte Suprema decida
ellos pueden decidir que ya no es
relevante esto significa aniquilar por
completo el sistema judicial
Este es el primer paso hacia el fin de
la democracia en Israel y sin democracia
no tendremos nada We Will have nothing
pesa la masiva movilización y a un
llamado del presidente Isaac soc que
anoche le pidió a los partidos políticos
negociar una reforma alternativa El
Ejecutivo de netaniagu continuó con sus
planes hoy y le dio una primera votación
en comisiones a los primeros puntos de
esta reforma en particular el que le
permite al gobierno de turno tener la
mayoría en la elección de los jueces lo
que permite pensar que estas
movilizaciones seguirán continuando por
un tiempo